there's never a good day for a super
villain attack or a tense Feud with your
closest sibling and for the Mighty Thor
this day was turning out to be both as
the self-proclaimed strongest Avenger
flung his body across the planet Earth
using his trusty Magical Hammer Monier
the Asgardian steeled himself for yet
another confrontation with his evil
half-brother Loki the god of Mischief as
per usual Loki was terrorizing the
humans of a random City using his
allusions to manifest imaginary dragons
and other ferocious beasts and what was
also usual is Thor had no idea what his
brother's motive or endgame was all the
God of Thunder knew was that this kind
of trickery decree would not be stood
for while these terrible creatures
weren't real they were still very
frightening to the earthlings civilians
were running around in every direction
away from Loki and this was causing all
kinds of chaos and traffic disturbances
regardless of what Loki's plan was
Thorne knew that his brother had to be
be stopped before things escalated
further on Earth humans needed to rely
on vehicles to get around and even the
slightest inconvenience in
transportation could lead to disaster
Thor touched down in the same City
Square where Loki was unleashing his
horde of Make-Believe monsters Landing
in a classically cool superhero way
hello brother Thor proclaimed I don't
suppose you'll be stopping this without
a fight Loki smiled a mischievous smile
and replied I thought we meet again and
once again you're wrong I can stop this
anytime I walked Loki swiftly moved his
hand through the air casting a new spell
to dismiss his diabolical decoys the
Illusions dispersed naturally and soon
the two brothers were facing each other
one on one see
Loki chuckled Thor was rightly confused
by his brother's unpredictable actions
he pointed molnir towards Loki in an
accusatory manner no Illusions no
sorcery what you really playing at Loki
said Thor and then Loki reached into his
robes and produced an unusual
cube-shaped object as his good brother
was all too aware this particular Cube
was the latest in a long line of
mysterious and Powerful cubes that Loki
had used for his various evil plans Loki
juggled the unknown Cube from one hand
to the other then waved it in the air in
front of Thor and began to laugh
maniacally all I need to do is open this
ancient box of mysteries and I'll become
completely Unstoppable don't you dare do
it Loki Thor shouted that sort of power
will be misused in your hands that's
precisely the point Loki continued to
laugh then Reach For What appeared to be
the lid of the cube he grabbed the top
of it and made a show of beginning to
twist this and Thor's heroic instincts
into high gear and he threw molnir at
the cube knocking it out of Loki's grasp
as the cube flew away from the grinning
villain Thor Dove to retrieve it before
his brother had the chance you soon held
the strange item in one hand while
calling molnir back to the other as Thor
stared at the cube pondering its purpose
Loki stretched out his hands in
desperation oh no not by Cube if you
open it now my plan is doomed Loki
pleaded Thor responded with a laugh of
his own nice try brother but I'm going
to open it and so the God of Thunder did
Thor popped the Cube's lid and braced
himself for whatever Cosmic force was
about to be released but for some reason
nothing happened still curious Thor took
a cautious look inside as it turned out
the only thing within this apparently
non-magical Cube was what appeared to be
a fully developed photograph what an
Odin's name is this Thor removed the
image and held it close to his face it
appeared to depict an emaciated pale
humanoid with long spindly limbs
standing in the corner of a compact room
with smooth metal walls in all his many
years traveling the nine Realms Thor had
never seen anything like it whatever the
creature actually was it certainly did
not look happy of course what Thor was
actually looking at was a photo taken of
scp-096 inside of its containment unit
at the foundation the shy guy as its
nickname suggested did not like having
its face looked at even via secondary
means such as photography or video
recording the anomalous humanoid sense
of Shame about its own appearance was so
great that a mere moment after Thor
fixed his Asgardian Eyes Upon its Visage
scp-096 began to stir in its containment
unit the creature whale then covered its
face with both of its hands on its long
sinewy arms it screamed and carried on
for a duration of two minutes after
which point scp-096 sprinted towards the
steel walls of its containment unit and
smashed through reaching speeds greater
than most Motor Vehicles
scp-096 began to zero in on Thor's
location
as was always the case when another
being saw its face the shy guy was
compelled to utterly annihilate the
offending Observer with its bare hands
Thor himself had no idea that scp-096
was in route and continued to squint at
the photograph perplexed by the
mysterious entity depict therein Loki
now resumed his mad laughter because
once more he had managed to trick his
foolish brother into falling for one of
his ingenious schemes make sure to get a
good look brother Loki gloated yes look
at the full creature that will bring
about your inevitable destruction Thor
was annoyed if you think that showing me
a gross picture of some lowly wretch
will strike fear into my heart you've
truly forgotten what it means to be an
Asgardian save your sentiments for the
halls of Valhalla the green clad
evildoer cackled you'll be there soon
enough and with that Loki used a charm
to turn himself invisible and vanish
completely from Thor's sight Thor
stumped his phone It On The Ground
angrily who wasn't sure how but it
seemed as though Loki had gotten the
last laugh once again Loki he shouted
after his brother come back here and
face me with honor then the God of
Thunder sighed pensively and thought to
himself who am I kidding he's never
going to change Thor looked at his
trusty Hammer Mo and your old friend it
seems like we've saved the day yet again
shall we away back to Avengers HQ he
then shook molnir up and down like a
puppeteer simulating a nod Splendid idea
ammonia glad you thought of it Thor
chuckled already in better spirits
that's when he began to hear the
footsteps of scp-096 rapidly approaching
him Thor turned his head towards the
sound and saw the same disquieting
Creature from the photograph that was
inside Loki's Cube zooming headlong
towards him with Reckless abandon the
Asgardian blinked he almost couldn't
believe his eyes whatever that thing was
it was faster than Thor could have
possibly anticipated was it looking for
the photograph he won hello there Thor
called out as scp-096 continued to make
a beeline at the Caped superhero the God
of Thunder waved the photograph of
scp-096 in the air is this your um
selfie in all likelihood Loki had been
his usual conniving self and stole that
self-portrait from the miserable
creature hoping that it would mistake
Thor for the thief the god of Mischief
had probably even used a glamor to
disguise himself as Thor when he did the
deed Thor believed that all he had to do
was clear up this misunderstanding and
that he and this strange Beast could go
their separate ways without coming to
blows it was a naive optimistic and
ultimately incorrect view of the
situation but at least the hero's heart
was in the right place I don't need this
so Thor said trying to reason with the
creature you can have it back if you'd
like but scp-096 showed no signs of
stopping and was seemingly enraged even
further by Thor flaunting its decidedly
unflattering photograph the shy guy
kicked the ground and shot forward with
a powerful burst of speed one of its
elongated arms slammed into Thor's face
with enough Force to nearly knock the
Asgardian off his feet Thor was so
surprised that he instinctively whacked
the creature with molnir sending scp-096
careening backwards down the street it
wasn't launched more than a dozen feet
before its powerful arms and legs dug
into the pavement and slowed its
velocity to zero even though the thing
from the photo had taken a direct hit
from molnir it barely looked phased on a
physical level one thing was for sure
the shy guy was still incredibly
distraught and it was directing all of
those negative emotions towards the God
of Thunder what was this thing what is
this thing Thor wondered to himself it
was fast strong and durable to an
unearthly degree if this thing wanted to
engage in single combat Thor wouldn't
back down he was an Asgardian Warrior
and sometimes that meant facing
challenges head on no matter how
suddenly they arose still his time with
the Avengers had taught him that having
a clear reason to fight was sometimes
even more important than the fight
itself hey quick question um what are
you he said aloud to the creature
scp-096 didn't answer within seconds it
was on Thor again like a build snipe on
another build snipe the screaming
humanoid swung wildly pelting its
opponent with blow after blow Thor tried
once more to communicate with his
unknown enemy I have no quarrel with you
weird one Thor spoke so take your noodle
arms and be gone for all of its
Relentless ferocity the humanoid
Abomination left countless openings that
a seasoned Warrior like Thor could
easily exploit of course most mortal
combatants would be unable to endure the
brunt of the Shy Guy's attacks for long
enough but true to his nature Thor was a
god The Avengers struck back with
another crushing blow from molnir aimed
straight for the creature sternum once
again the monster was pushed back for a
moment and then resumed its maddening
Onslaught a blow like that should have
at least busted a rib or two where the
bones of this horrible thing made a
vibranium or some other rare metal out
of the depths of space Thor realized he
was now fighting on the defensive while
he had faced foes in the past with much
greater physical strength than the shy
guy including his superhero colleague
Bruce Banner's mean green ever-loving
Alter Ego The Incredible Hulk the sheer
tenacity of scp-096 meant that being
careless with his own protection could
lead to Thor taking unnecessary hits
that would eventually wear him down in a
prolonged fight the ryrie humanoid
certainly didn't show any signs of
slowing down or tiring even though it
had to be expending a lot of energy to
move so quickly between his alternating
deflections and counter blows against
the creature Thor mold over his
brother's words from earlier Loki was
right about one thing this is a fell
Creature if ever there was one still as
long as there is thunder in my blood I
won't allow a hairless curl like this to
bring me my own destruction think for
what would Stark do at a time like this
he says he's the smart one after all
humor him with his highly sophisticated
tactical Acumen that was similar to Iron
Man except for the fact that it was much
better and stronger Thor efficiently
assessed his current situation while the
pale Beast was undoubtedly violent and
far mightier than most terrestrial
creatures its attention and all the
brute strength that came with it have
been fixated solely on Thor since it
arrived in the city the asgardian's best
guest as to why was the photograph that
Loki had tricked him into looking at
devious trickster that he is Loki must
have known that this thing would hunt
down and attempt to pulverize the latest
being to see its face which now of
course happened to be Thor the
revelation of this fact meant that Thor
no longer had to worry about the fate of
civilians if he chose to relocate to a
less populated Battlefield since the
creature was now guaranteed to follow
nobody else needed to get hurt while
running from the fight wasn't exactly
the god of Thunder's favorite strategy
who would massively reduce the chance of
collateral damage he'd be saving lives
in classic Avengers fashion Captain
America would be so proud not that Thor
would have done it any differently even
if he didn't have the Star-Spangled
man's approval
scp-096 leaped in towards Thor to
deliver its next whopping strike but the
Asgardian quickly grounded by the wrist
and pulled the Ferocious creature off
its feet he lifted it up and over his
head before slamming it down hard into
the pavement with a bit of space between
himself and his anomalous foe Thor began
to swing molnir around by its leathery
wrist strap the shy guy desperately
scrambled to its feet to resume the
attack but by that time Thor had already
thrown himself Skyward he soared between
the buildings using the force of
molnir's trajectory making it his
mission to exit the city as soon as
possible Thor looked down to see that
scp-096 was following him along the
round exactly as he predicted it would
well the battle with the Beast would
most certainly continue the second he
dropped back to Earth's surface he could
rest assured that the place where the
Showdown would take place could be
chosen by him he saw an evergreen forest
on a nearby mountain and decided that it
would do nicely as a place to finish
this I'm sure no one would mind a few
stray bolts of lightning around here
Thor thought the God of Thunder was
amused by the prospect of going all out
against this being even though it
probably had its reasons for wanting to
destroy the one that saw its face Thor
was past the point of Taking Chances on
diplomacy this distressing creature was
after all an adversary that Loki had
plotted to send after him through one
means or another and because of that it
was likely to have power and guile to
spare Thor breaking his sweat to
Vanquish the thing would be a fitting
replacement for the fight that he would
have to have with Loki Thor's feet hit
the ground on a Stony Mountain ledge and
once again he struck that icon Onyx
superhero Landing pose remarkably the
shy guy had kept pace with Thor almost
the entire time the S Guardian had been
flying smashing through every tree in
Boulder that stood in its path even so
Thor was more than ready for it storm
clouds rumbled overhead the sky above
the mountain was trembling as Thor
decided that it was time to bring down
the thunder on his unfortunate foe boom
crack the heavens flashed with
electrical might as Thor channeled the
energy from several lightning bolts
through molnir before unleashing a
Consolidated blast of unbridled power
onto scp-096 the shy guy didn't even
attempt to dodge as Thor's thundershock
treatment bombarded it with light and
heat the likes of which few Mortals
could withstand Thor released a second
blast then a third surrounding scp-096
with as much lightning as these Earthly
Skies would offer him after keeping at
this for a while Thor decided to let up
momentarily to check in on his foe only
to see that there were no tons of
visible damage on the creature it wasn't
even slightly singed the God of Thunder
could feel his brother laughing at him
from somewhere out of sight and Out Of
Reach the Monstrous humanoid in the
forest below was proving to be far more
than Thor had bargained for but he was
nowhere near ready to give in and accept
defeat still maybe this wasn't a fight
worth having on Earth all Thor's
electrical attacks were doing was
destroying trees and the planet was
already facing unprecedented levels of
deforestation due to the greed of human
CEOs and Shady entrepreneurs Thor
certainly didn't want to be part of the
problem and now that it was occurring to
him he realized that he should probably
try to do something about that once the
situation with the shy guy was resolved
it didn't matter how close of a friend
Elon Musk was to Tony Stark these
overreaching humans had to be given a
Stern talking to by the God of Thunder
with or without hammer in his hand of
course Thor's environmentalist concerned
had to go on the back burner for now
since scp-096 was advanced towards him
once again with no hint of slowing down
let's see if you can follow me back to
Asgard you son of an elf Thor thought he
held his hammer Aloft and counted on
hemdal to deploy the bifrost the Rainbow
Bridge arrives seconds before
scp-096's arms would have reached the
Asgardian and as expected it instantly
carried Thor into the interdimensional
space between his destinations amidst
the swirling sea of multi-colored lights
Thor shared a laugh with nobody but
himself and molnir so much for shy guy
said Thor looks like he'll have to
resolve those body issues on its own
time I've been through something similar
so I can relate best of luck pitiful
beast but while Thor was congratulating
himself for his strategic Retreat he
almost didn't notice that his foe hadn't
actually stopped in its Pursuit as a
matter of fact scp-096 was currently
inside of the bifrost and swiftly
gaining on the God of Thunder the shy
guy was truly running in the 90s well 90
miles per hour or more but it made the
same difference the creature grabbed
Thor by his ankles and screeched in
mortified rage Thor punched scp-096 in
the face hoping to shake it off but to
no avail the two opponents spun through
the bifrost locked together in an
unbreakable grapple until they collided
with the walls of interdimensional space
Thor knew exactly where this was going
and he wasn't happy about it like a
sheet of ice composed of photons the
outer limits of the bifrost broke away
sending both combatants shooting off
into the void seconds later a wormhole
spit Thor and scp-096 out in a vast
junkyard filled with the remains of
countless spaceships and alien life
forms great I'm trapped in this garbage
world again I knew I should have picked
somewhere closer Thor shook off the
nauseating effects of the failed
interdimensional trip
scp-096 was already hail and Hardy for
another round Thor grimaced with
frustrated anticipation uh how about a
quick five minute wrist Thor implored
the shy guy gentlemen struce
scp-096 Ward and dash fourth more crazed
than ever Thor exhaled in futility I
thought not he whipped Monir around and
hurled it straight for scp-096's skull
the reliable uru steel Hammer made
contact knocking the creature onto its
back at the very least Thor could always
count on his signature weapon to help
him out or could he when the Asgardian
tried to call the hammer back he was
shocked to find that scp-096 had somehow
grabbed a hold of its handle even more
surprisingly it now appeared to be
wielding the Hammer as easily as Thor
could Sonoma you're telling me that
thing is worthy the shy guy now with
molnir in hand pounced on Thor Swinging
The Hammer with no technique or finesse
it was everything Thor could do to
Simply avoid the creature's range a blow
from molnir was enough to cause serious
injury to even the most formidable
Asgardian Warrior Damu Monier we talked
about this Thor Thunder we're friends
aren't we the none of his words could
get through to the Hammer now that it
was in the hand of
scp-096 in an act of righteous Defiance
Thor called The Fury of lightning into
his own body this strange foe which had
come from Loki's latest prank was about
to find out what happened when a god of
thunder got serious with the speed of a
lightning bolt Thor flew at scp-096 and
punched it so hard that it script
loosened on molnir for all but a second
and that second was all Thorn needed to
reclaim his weapon his hand clung
tightly to molnir's handle as he swung
the weapon into the Shy Guy's body with
all of his might the shock wave of this
forceful blow launched piles of debris
High into the air and sent scp-096
tumbling across the surface of the
planet like a thrown piece of discarded
food at an Asgardian Feast with another
pulse of electricity Thor magnetized the
portions of the rubble which contained
spaceship parts and used his
manipulation of that same energy to bury
the shy guy in the deepest heap of trash
he could manage and with one last flick
of molnir Thor sent himself hurtling
through the largest wormhole in the sky
above and back into space where it would
be far more difficult for his foe to
follow him finally with some distance
Thor breathed to sigh of relief you
almost had me that time Loki what an
unusual being fought like a Berserker
but was somehow also pure of heart the
kindred spirit to myself perhaps even so
I truly hope to never meet that thing
again now go check out scp-096 versus
scp-343 and scp-049 cures scp-096 of the
pestilence for more battles with this
self-conscious skinny Legend